good morning everybody my name is David
smithette I will be the uh legal advisor
for the purposes of today's review
hearing today is Thursday the 12th of
November 2020 the time is 10 a.m good
morning councilors good morning those
who are present
um
the purpose of today's hearing uh
okay
fast to the hearing regulations
2005. before we proceed to the review
hearing proper there are some initial
matters that I would just like to make
the committee and those in attendants
aware of
firstly I remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
YouTube and will be capable of repeated
viewing
the meeting will be recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record or film or
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully excluded
now given that this is a virtual hearing
they're just some virtual meeting
etiquette that I would remind everybody
about for the smooth running of today's
hearing firstly can you please ensure
that microphones are muted when you're
not speaking
secondly that you do not interrupt other
speakers
thirdly that if you are attending a
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave the meeting
and additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chair and
I will just ask you to please all wait
your turn those are the initial
narratives that I would like to make
clear to you all
second matter on the agenda is election
of the chairman for the hearing so far
as today's review hearing is concerned I
I can confirm that the chairman will be
councilor Mark Newman councilor Mark
Newman and that being the case uh Mr
chairman I would ask you to proceed with
the agenda
lovely thank you David
um welcome to everybody to this virtual
meeting of the licensing subcommittee
um apologies for absence Karen none
received chair
uh Declarations of Interest
um yes Mr chairman I think I ought to
just clarify
um because there was an interest that I
took part in the plan and process that
granted plan and permission for this
um venue which was nothing to do or any
reference to any licensing that may
happened afterwards thank you okay thank
you anymore no okay
all right now we've moved to some
introductions as you've heard I'm
councilor Mark Newman the chairman
um my committee Sue would you like to
introduce yourself morning councilor Sue
carpentel
Peter
good morning everybody uh counselor
Peter here
um legal officer you've already heard
from him but
David good morning my name's David
smithette
um from West Suffolk Council shared
legal service
um legal advisor for this morning and
today
David
price licensing officer for the meeting
assistant manager of food and safety
Emma
good morning I'm Emma Rich bell
assistant manager food safety and
Licensing
uh governance officer Karen
good morning everyone Karen say a
governance officer
okay lovely um the applicant um is that
Trevor as well would you like to
introduce yourself Trevor
good morning everybody my name's uh
Trevor Creswell and I'm a resident of
Borum gate Precinct
do you want to introduce any Witnesses
with you
um I have uh Mr dorrington with me um I
will pass the phone so uh Mr dorrington
can uh also um speak
good morning I'm Mr Darlington form 26
born gate Precinct
okay thank you uh premises license
um is it dad's would you like to
introduce yourself
yes good morning uh members Mr chairman
I'm David dads I'm Council and I
represent the premise license holder
thank you um David uh Mr dad did you
receive um all relevant representation
uh
all what I've received I I have it's
okay
um I believe I have everything that I I
ought to have um Mr chairman
jolly good that's what I need to know um
Suffolk constabury would you like to
introduce yourself I think this is
Sharon yes good morning Sharon Betts
Palmer licensing officer for Suffolk
constabulary
um Robert
is it a robber or not they might not be
on yet yeah but there will be Robert
Farrow and Oliver Williams for South
African style okay no that's that's fine
thank you Environmental Protection
Officer um is that uh Chris
Mr chairman yes Chris Cornish it's
senior environmental health of
Environmental Protection Team
okay Thank You Les is
Protection Officer all right great and
now we've got planning enforcement
officer
good morning yes uh Simon Bailey from
the planning enforcement team
I believe we've got um other persons I
think is there Donna
would you like to introduce yourself
Donna
um
Steve Hall no Steve's not attending
either
uh Doug you've he just introduced him
yeah
lovely and uh Joanne Joann's not
attending either okay
all right that's jolly good and uh right
we'll now move on yeah so you have a
question from Council for the premises
license holder
okay Dad solicit are you would you like
to ask you a question yes uh
um could I just so that I'm absolutely
clear who's attending for who because
obviously I've got the agenda but I've
got no individual witness statements so
um in relation to the police
um you mentioned the couple other names
I didn't quite get that down quick
enough I've got Sharon
okay
sorry sorry
um Council um
um I will get to that part for the
witness part there's a question for the
witness for for myself as licensing
officer so when we get to that part I'll
I'll speak out the full names of each
witness would that be more appropriate
but there's a there's a question there's
a question for like there's two
questions for lasting officer which
we're not at that stage yet in the
procedure there are two questions and
one of them is obviously the witnesses
no it's that's that's not what I'm
raising and it might be that the legal
officer will understand that the point
I'm making I miss Jim and you will I'm
just saying I I want to know who's in
attendance uh and why they're going to
be in tendons and uh whether they've
made relevant representations uh if
they're a witness then I under the uh
hearing regulation should have been
informed in advance five days in advance
of whip witness is going to be called a
copy of their evidence so I have an
opportunity to look at that evidence and
be ready for cross-examination so at the
moment I've not been informed of two
other officers that you mentioned from
the um constabury so I'm seeking
clarification a moment who who is here
in attendance
um and um what's their capacity and I
think as you're doing a roll call I
thought it would be appropriate to do it
now
uh okay a legal officer can you help
with this yeah I think that's
appropriate I think and that's a fair
question for Mr dad
um so far as the police are concerned
who are the witnesses who are going to
be given evidence today he wants to
clarify whether those their statements
have been provided to to him so that he
can prepare for cross-examination
it's a fair point made
so uh Dave Price can we give them to him
now
the witnesses obviously the the main
person speaking on behalf of Suffolk and
stabbury is Sharon Betts Palmer
thank you
and the two witnesses for Suffolk
contemporary
depending on the permission of the
committee
uh Robert
pharaoh
yeah yes and Oliver Williams
uh sorry and I should have clarified and
I'm sure the legal advisor also um
agreed me it's not actually
cross-examination but to ask points of
clarification or questions but I I've
not I've not got any witness statements
for those two gentlemen
um but we'll cover that when it when it
comes to their Evidence Act but
um they're from the environmental health
I see that we have a number of
individuals from environmental health do
we need could we just clarify who is the
main speaker and who's the witness is so
I can get their names down as well Mr
chairman and it will help me prepare for
this morning or today or two days
okay David can you yes to the main
speaker for Environmental Protection is
Chris Cornish
and his Witnesses are James Buckingham
and Les King
okay
I think I've got um some questions at
Trevor queswell if you've got a question
you've got your hand up
sorry I was on mood um sorry all I was
going to say I I did uh email David this
morning my son was going to
um speak today but he's been brought to
work
um and he's left me a statement that um
at some point I'd like to read if that's
okay
or you can read that out in your
presentation yes that's fine yeah okay
it might just take me a few extra
minutes that's all because I think
there's only a two-minute statement
anyway
okay we'll be asking that question in a
minute how long you expect to take right
um I think we've got hands up for Sharon
baked Palmer have you got a question
Sharon
um it's not a question it's just a
clarification
um Robert Caro will not be attending he
can't gain access uh Sergeant Oliver
Williams will he's not a witness Cafe
he's here to assist me if there's any
questions in regards to Sudbury or the
area as I do not normally cover Sudbury
so I don't know the area I don't really
know the premises
okay thank you um David dad you got a
question again
yes thank you
um I I think it's good just to clarify
these points before we we start so
clarify now from the police that neither
of those are witnesses and that probably
explains why I haven't been notified in
advance so I'm happy that's clarified in
relation to environmental health
um James Buckingham and Les King I've
not been notified in advance that they
are going to be Witnesses and I haven't
seen their witness statements in
addition to that Trevor a counselor
um Trevor excuse me one moment all these
names crosswell
um he refers to his son and I think he's
referring to someone called Thomas or
Tom
um but I don't know if that gentleman
his son made representations within 28
days if he did then he can inform the
licensing Authority that he wants
someone to speak on his behalf if he
hasn't made a representation in 28 days
I'm sure your legal advisor will advise
you that he's not allowed to have a
statement read in this hearing this
morning I'm sorry this is all paperwork
and admin but it's best to get started
on the right track I think you'll agree
Mr chairman yeah okay thank you David
legal advisor please David
um I think we have to clarify when
representations were made by Tom
Creswell within the required time
okay
um Mr Creswell wants to speak actually I
think he's got his hand up
yes
sorry yes um Tom did make representation
within the 28 days that he wished to
speak
um and uh was on the list to speak
and I did um
email uh licensing officer David Price
yesterday to say that um I may need to
speak on Tom's behalf
thank you
okay legal advisor is that okay
uh sorry I'm just
checking regulations at the moment
um so what was that I missed
Mr Creswell could you repeat that please
yes what I said was at the time uh Tom
Tom did write into the to the council
and we are asked to speak uh and he was
um
on the list to speak
um and also I
because Tom's work I wrote to David
Price and said that I would like to read
a statement from Tom today and uh I was
told that should not be a problem thank
you
okay legal advisor
David
I've just got a query from Mr dad's Kent
Mr dad's can you confirm where within
the licensing regulations there's uh
confirmation that a party needs to
notify to other parties or Witnesses or
witnesses that they're going to be
calling
yes I'm happy to do that it's under the
premier series licensing regulations I
think
um I'll get these references it's quite
some time since I've looked at that
regulation but if you bear with me one
minute and whilst I'm just looking for
that I think it might be around
regulation 25 or 6 but I'll just recap
my memory
um in its five days notice but while I'm
doing that Mr Germany it could be that
um Mr Price could just clarify because I
haven't seen it on the agenda it might
be my an over oversight on my behalf but
I haven't seen a representation from Tom
Creswell within the 28 days so whilst
I'm just looking at the regulation
perhaps that could be clarified if you
wouldn't mind would you give me a minute
to look up the regulation yeah certainly
no I've got some more questions anyway
David Price can you answer that one
legal officer
chair I'm busy looking at the
regulations at the same at this precise
moment in time at the same time I'm
looking at the hearing regulations 2005.
um
regulation 25 relates to the authority
may require any person who attended I'm
not sure whether it requires
um a party to clarify a witness who's
going to be attending at a review
hearing
but Mr dad's May clarify what specific
uh rule that he's referring to
chat
um I'll come back on your question on uh
Tom Creswell Tom Creswell is part of the
residence Association is permitted to
speak
okay
David dad so are you happy with that
uh no but I'll come back to you in a
minute one one matter at a time if I may
can we just clarify that he didn't write
in within the 28 days as an individual
and himself
Association he's permit to speak on that
on that side okay
on the document don't we yeah well could
I address you that with that in a moment
Mr chairman as I'm doing one thing and I
don't want to be seen to be cutting you
short with a short answer but I just
need to find my regulations to deal with
the witness Point first if you don't
mind will you carry on with that I think
we've got some more questions
um I think Sharon
baked Palmer have you got a question uh
no apologies I forgot to take my hand
down all right uh Chris Cornish
got your hand up
sorry
Environmental Protection is as a
responsible Authority the written
evidence has been submitted and Les King
and James Buckingham will be here with
regards to questions to the responsible
authorities evidence they are part of
the environment and therefore
responsible Authority
okay thank you Peter B has been waiting
to speak Peter uh well most demands been
picked up Mr chairman by so I think but
I was just one point
um the um Mr dubs did refer to uh Trevor
Mr Trevor Creswell as counselor I think
to be clear uh he is here in a private
capacity uh and it's only fair we should
refer to him as Mr Trevor Creswell and
he will referring to his son that would
be Mr Tom Creswell
um I don't think we should confuse the
fact that he is a second counselor at
this moment in time but he's certainly
not here as that and it would be unfair
I think to give that impression I'm sure
that wasn't the intention but I think it
just clarifies it all rain for everybody
thank you we know that thank you cancer
beer uh Trevor Creswell you got a
question
or response
yes thank you Peter you're dead right I
have came as an individual as a resident
of where I live and not as a town
counselor and what I say today isn't as
a town councilor but as a local resident
of aurum gate Precinct and
um
I think thank you for saying that
because um
I'm ready to answer the first point and
then I've I've been trying to listen to
the representations I I would like to
respond to that in a moment but
certainly in relation to um Witnesses I
apologize the um because I haven't
looked at this for a number of years but
obviously I remember it so it's actually
in relation to regulation
um eight it says in a case of a party
wishes another part another person other
than the person he intends to represent
at the hearing to appear at the hearing
notice should be in paragraph one shall
contain a request for permission for
such person to appear at the hearing
accompanied by the details of the name
of the person and a brief description of
the point or points which to be made
um able to assist the authority in the
application representations and notice
making the request sets it out each
party shall give no later than two
working days before the day five days on
which the hearings to be held in other
in any other case the party shall give
note is no later than five working days
before the day of the hearing so if for
example
um Mr Tom Creswell is to be called as a
witness for the residence Association
which I'll come to in a minute then I
should have been notified in advance of
today's hearing should have been given a
a brief outline of what he wanted to say
because if you think about it he could
call any Resident under the resident
Association if I've got no proof of the
Constitution the members its membership
and anything that's said in that
statement I haven't had in advance and
it would be unfair moreover he hasn't
written as an individual plus also I
haven't seen whether this residence
Association is properly constituted does
it have a constitution is it
unconstituted where is its members so
coming back to the point about pregnancy
it is important if the environment to
health officer who's made the
representation he signs his
representation or gives his
representation and under the licensing
act it's clear that the responsible
Authority can make its representation
and one officer would do that anyone
else coming and being called as a
witness should be be notified to me and
told and for me to be told what is their
evidence that they're reducing so I can
prepare for that witness and no
different to the police environmental
health no different to the residents
Association now if the residents feel
that they are going to be prejudiced or
any party to the preceding feels that
they're going to be prejudiced
I have no objection to a German I don't
want to adjourn because I don't want
people thinking that this is a legal
argument that I'm pursuing try to
exclude evidence I'm not trying to do
that but what I am trying to do is make
sure we have a fair hearing on behalf of
the premise license holder and and if
there are any Wings ah the legal advisor
is on the telephone so I don't think
he's heard any of the submission I've
made and I ought to pause from it and
make it again
legal advisor did you get that
David
we'll just pause for a moment thank you
Mr chairman
I didn't see him on screen but then I
saw him come on to screen with a
telephone
yeah
we'll just get clarification
that's fine and I don't mind doing it
again sorry
that's fine that's fine thank you
I know Chris Cornish is waiting with a
question but we'll sort this one out
first Chris and then we'll come to you
um could I just uh ask the question why
we're waitems for these answers uh to
David Price
um that's canceled beer here
um
the the
what is it the applicant
uh
is not limited by time and speaking so I
mean he could actually
make his comments regardless of whether
um we had an additional witness readout
letter in that in that uh slot is that
so Mr chairman so that we could proceed
David Price would you any advice on that
or do we need legal on that one yeah we
need to to speak to Legal first yeah I
think I think I thought it was a simple
answer but there's not I I would like an
opportunity just to speak with the
committee in private please
is this a legal issue that I would like
to um clarify with the committee members
okay so can uh what should we do go to
private Mr chairman yeah calendar yeah
Mr chairman sorry team trucks no you
don't mind
um Mr Smith is would you like to hear my
submissions back in reply to the points
I've made before you retire yeah that
would be great for Mr Dad thank you very
much is that right with you Mr chairman
yeah that's great yeah please repeat
that again thank you yes thank you so
thank you very much the the um the point
that I was asked to clarify is in
relation to the hearing regulations
regarding Witnesses and I've referred to
the regulation Aid that in essence if a
party wishes to call a witness then they
are to give um notice
um in advance normally five working days
and they should detail their name and um
uh and and a brief that's right and a
brief detail uh of the points or the
descriptions they wish to make at the
hearing to assist the authority you make
in its applications or representations
so I should be noted notified in advance
uh Equity of arms I I for a fair hearing
of any Witnesses are to be called with a
copy of either their statement or a note
of what why they're being called and
what they're going to say so I can
prepare for a hearing and I think you
will agree with me that that makes
common common sense
um so in relation to the police we've
already had it clarified that they're
not Witnesses in relation to
environmental health we've heard that
James Buckingham and Les King are going
to be called as Witnesses I haven't been
notified that in advance and I've had
I've seen no witness statement for those
individuals however if it is said that
all the officers have co-joinedly made
the representation jointly that is not
clear for from the representation made
and also I think it needs to be quite
clear who's saying what where so then I
can appropriately ask that particular
officer it may be that the environmental
secant in German just to clarify their
position
re reposition themselves as it were and
come back for the committee when I can
prepare for it properly in relation to
Trevor Creswell he says he acts for a
resident Association it looks like it's
unincorporated but that and I have no
problems with that at all obviously I
may question about its validity and the
resolution and members but Tom Creswell
we know has not made a representation in
28 days we have been told today for the
first time that he's a member certainly
I'm being told the first time he is a
member of the association if the
association are calling him as a witness
I've not been notified in advance
moreover I haven't had a copy of the
statement that is going to be read on
his behalf today day so therefore I am
prejudiced that would need to be
disclosed in advance if even if it's
accepted that he is a member of the
association I've not seen a member
members list I haven't seen signatures
of her members I've not seen a
resolution or the Constitution as
councilor carpentel with lewd to
normally when you have a residence
Association you would have a list of the
members and the names as I say in
relation to that submission
that's all I have have to say at this
point
all right David legal do you want to
still any comment on that or do you want
to go into private no I think I'm
grateful for Mr dad for those um
submissions that he's made I would like
to have an opportunity of of going into
private session with the uh committee
please can I just quickly clarify
the question yeah Chris has been waiting
to Chris Cornish yeah just very quickly
James Buckingham and Les King will only
be talking about matters raised in the
written submission so for example there
are references to Environmental
Protection contacting license holder and
reference to Environmental Protection
offices and what they witnessed what
their spoken evidence will be is in
reference to the written submission if
needed so thank you uh David dads would
that be acceptable uh no because I don't
I have not seen their witness statements
it's this is not the proper way Mr
chairman if okay if an officer is going
to be called then I would expect their
witness statement or to be told at least
what point it may be that we can have a
short German and Chris and I uh if he
doesn't mind me referring to Mr Cornish
and I could have a quick conversation
and he could identify who's doing what
and then it means that I'm prepared
because I will need to know when I'm
here in the officer which officer I am
um questioning about the evidence
because if I don't question at the right
time the right Witness it could be
presumed under the civil law on evidence
that I accept that submission and then
later on I realized actually I've I've
not asked the question of the relevant
witness so it is important we know who
is making the representation which
Witnesses are being called and their
evidence they're attending so I can then
have an opportunity to ask questions and
seek points of clarification as well as
you members will want to do the same
okay Dave thank you uh Chris Cornish do
you want to come back your hands up
apologies I should have lowered it and
uh no problem what people want to call
me it's absolutely fine
okay right
um Peter beer you've got a comment uh
well just listening to what's being said
uh our legal uh wants to speak to us
through in a moment I think perhaps Mr
chairman and perhaps our legal can
confirm that if Mr dubs and Mr Cornish
were quite happy to have a chat that
might clear clear that particular point
up because I don't think there's too
much of a difficulty there
um so I don't know whether that could
happen while we're having our little
chat or committee or is there something
that you wouldn't want to
um to go down that road
um
legal yeah David it will make good use
of time
um if the committee is away being
advised uh Mr dad and Mr Cornish wants
to speak with regards to those
particular aspects it makes sense
perhaps
German would be fine 10 minutes or would
you want longer
at least
okay to exclude the public before we um
do that
session and we'll pause this meeting and
pause the live stream
um I also move Mr chairman that we go
into private session yeah I've got to
read this out and okay
well we would do that at the end let me
read it out Mr chairman Mr chairman with
respect I think you're just a journey to
go and speak to your legal advisor we're
not going to private session at the
moment we're just adjourning
okay uh David legal advisor I think
that's right let's let's we're simply
adjourning for advice uh we're not
adjourning the actual
um hearing itself we're going into
private session so I think that's right
is any of the other members of the
public that are supporting us or
watching the the feed live so otherwise
they'll be excluded from listening later
on
thank you all right okay should we um we
need to leave this temporarily
yeah should we go back to our brief a
briefing meeting this morning should we
go to that one
on the calendar I'm sending you a new
one now oh wonderful okay so oh we've
got to leave this one yeah and we'll be
about 10-15 minutes I'd say okay
foreign
Mr chairman there are a number of
okay yeah legal advisor
we ready yep here we go um
I'm grateful for the submissions with or
the committee is great for the
submissions made on behalf of the
license holder
um in this matter uh and in particular
with regards to the importance of
notification of attendees and statements
and details being provided to other
parties
involved in the review hearing
I'm apologized for the fact that it's
taken a little bit longer than it had
been anticipated to advise the committee
there was an aspect that I wanted some
clarification upon but uh
the committee have asked me to clarify
the particular regulations that have
been highlighted these are the licensing
act 2003 hearings regulations 2005.
and in particular regulations eight and
regulation
um
22.
just clarify that
yep we're broadcast to paragraph
regulation
eight of the regulations which is headed
action following receipts of notice of
hearing regulation eight one States
quite simply a party shall give to the
authority within the period of time
provided for in the following provisions
of this regulation and notice stating
brackets little a whether he intends to
attend or be represented at the hearing
and little B
whether he considers a hearing to be
unnecessary
regulation eight two uh details as
follows in a case where a party wishes
any other person brackets other than the
person he intends to represent him at
the hearing those brackets to appear at
the hearing the note is referred to in
eight one so I contain a request for
permission for such other person to
appear at the hearing accompanied by
details of the name of that person and a
brief description of the point or points
in which that person may be able to
assist the authority in relation to the
application representations or notice of
the party making the request the reason
I've read that out in full is for the
fact that
with regards to the review hearing being
considered by baber District Council
an attendance at hearing form is
sent out and completed by the applicant
the license holder and all responsible
authorities that anyone else who intends
to
or has make clear that they intend to
make attendance and representations at
the hearing
and with regards to that attendance at
hearing form it not only
um
requires the names of those who will be
attending but secondly what reason they
will be attending and make submissions
about
with regards to the question of Tom
Thomas Creswell
that form I understand clarifies that he
is a resident
a resident near to the license holders
premises and that his attendance at the
hearing was to and I paraphrased give
details of his experience
of being a resident living next to that
license holder's premises
so far as
prior to today's concern
the committee understands that Thomas
Creswell was going to be taking up the
opportunity to
um
take up the opportunity to speak before
the committee
um and so
that being the case we are then told by
Trevor Creswell
that due to work commitment commitments
his son is not able to attend at this
review hearing to today
that being the case the committee have
then gone on to consider
regulation 22.
of the if I can abbreviate the 2005
regulations which is headed procedure at
hearing
and it states at the beginning of the
hearing the authority shall explain to
the parties the procedure which it
proposes to follow at the hearing and
shall consider any request made by a
party under regulation 8 brackets two
for permission for another person to
appear at the hearing such permission
shall not be unreasonable unreasonably
withheld
traffic Creswell has confirmed that due
to work commitments his son is unable to
appear at the review hearing and that
his son has provided a statement
which he asked the committee for
permission to read that out on behalf of
his son
the
situation from what that application uh
how it arises I suspect that it has
risen on today it's not something that
Mr Criswell may have known about before
but the committee has to consider
that application and has to consider
that permission for such a statement to
be read out it shall not be unreasonably
withheld
the committee have taken the view that
given the circumstances which have
pertained to Mr Creswell Junior if I can
put it that way not being able to attend
and make representations as had been
made known
um prior to today
that the application
made by Trevor Creswell
is a appropriate one to be made and it
has to consider whether that permission
for any statement to be read out to be
made and if so
whether it should or can be unreasonable
it would have held
the committee or overview that the
statement of Tom Creswell
can be read by Trevor Creswell
however
in reading out that statement
Trevor Creswell will be reading out a
hearsay statement
it's right that the committee are made
aware that it is a hearsay statement and
when the committee
retires to consider the evidence and
determine the application for review
that has been made before it
with regards to that hearsay statement
or any other hearsay statement that it
considers it has to apply what weight it
thinks is appropriate
given all the circumstances and how that
statement has come about
and why it has come about that it is
made today
as a more General view the count the
committee is of review that it is
appropriate for it to consider all
available evidence
In fairness to all parties
as it may have at its disposal
on the day of the review hearing and in
those circumstances whilst it is
prepared to enable Trevor Creswell to
read that statement it wished for Mr
Creswell Trevor Creswell and his son to
be made aware that because it is such a
hear statement the weight that the count
the committee attaches to it might
might not be as much as might have been
the case had any representations and or
submissions be made in person
I I hope that I've made that clear
um there were some points that I needed
clarification upon and I do apologize if
I've made it I hope I've made as full an
answer as I can and answered the queries
that have been raised by Mr dad on
behalf of the license holder I I know
that we've regards the issue raised as a
consequence of
um what evidence May well be called on
behalf of the Environmental Protection
Team there may well have been
conversations between Mr dad and Mr
Cornish
um it may be there may have been some
progress made it maybe that Mr dad's and
or Mr Cornish might want to clarify
the nature or if not the progress that
might have been made to the committee at
this point
okay thank you David uh David dads would
you like to come back yes thank you uh
Miss German as you'll be aware and your
legal advisor will advise you that any
advice that you have been given
um is provisional advice and it
obviously gets read out as it is now and
I should be given the opportunity to to
comment so I wonder if your permission
could I just comment Please Mr chairman
on on what I've just heard
yes of course yeah thank you
um whilst I I accept
if it is accepted by you may not
necessarily be accepted by me that
um
Tom Creswell made a representation
within 28 days then he is considered an
interested party another person to their
hearing uh you've heard that you Mr
chairman have said that you will hear
all evidence but you can only hear
evidence from those who are party to the
proceedings I made relevant
representations in 28 days
Mr Creswell Jr did not make a
representation in 28 days we have heard
that from Mr Price
therefore
um he cannot make any representations I
say now outside of the 28 days
of course he could be called as a
witness
for the residence Association and if Mr
Price confirms to me today that he has
been notified in advance
that Mr Cresswell a junior
was noted down as a witness for the
residence Association I would obviously
accept that as being the position
obviously of course I will make
representations on who is or who isn't
a member of the residence Association
whether it's constituted or
unconstituted but that's all I want to
say in relation to the business unit on
the comments made by Mr smithit in
relation to my my discourse and
discussions with the environmental
health
we have agreed a position going forward
and I don't think we need to uh trouble
you with that as we've agree agreed a
way forward in the in this hearing this
morning
so um one other point which I think I
need to unfortunately disagree with
councilor beer on
um and I will be standing corrected if
need be but counselor Cresswell is
councilor Cresswell
um he he has that title uh he is
councilor Cresswell he is a member of
your District Council he cannot
um
he can make a representation as
councilor Creswell as a resident he's
entitled to that not a problem but as a
matter of fact and law he's a counselor
of your District Council and that should
be on the public record that he is
because there may be a public perception
that he has access to officers or
information he's a District counselor
obviously it is of a public record it is
counselor and he's appearing before the
council
um or be in his personal capacity but he
is a counselor nevertheless and you know
I I I understand the difference
um but nevertheless he is a counselor
and I will be referring to Ms councilor
Creswell
okay thank you I'll just put Peter beard
you want to reply to that uh yes thank
you Mr chairman uh thank you Mr dubs
um yes I I'm well aware that he is an
elected member of baber District Council
and he's entitled to that uh title of
counselor but he in my opinion he's made
it clear in all the uh paperwork that
I've seen and what have you that is
Trevor Creswell leader of the born gay
residence Association and I don't want
him confused because quite often I'll
refer to my colleagues as counselor
Newman counselor cartandale I I will not
refer to Mr Trevor Creswell in any of
this here and as cancellator as well
um because
um it is separate to that but I've never
questioned that he's not a counselor I
respect that position that he is I've
just made it clear that as far as I'm
concerned and I like everybody else to
be aware that he is speaking as a
private individual in this case yes he
does have a title I'm sure sir you have
a proper title
um and um so from that point of view
um I I don't think I need to say any
more on that matter thank you okay thank
you Peter um Sharon Bert's Palmer have
you got something to say
uh yes and just to be open and
transparent really
um whilst you're in your
um private meeting Mr dad's asked me to
ring him and he wished to know why the
licensing office of a Sudbury
um wasn't present to advise that Mr
mckessor doesn't work on Thursdays or
Fridays
um he then um discussed with me
um his concerns with our representation
um and discussed visits and asked me to
send over any details or visits that had
been made I've spoken with my management
and they say that um it should have been
asked for prior to the hearing and that
we won't be sending it over during the
hearing
okay thank you
um
legal advisor any more comments before
we move on
no I've got no further comments at this
time
okay right we'll move on to the agenda
again and any parting to the hearing
wishes to withdraw either their
application or their representation
so it's uh Sharon have you got something
to say there your hands up again
apologies I keep forgetting to put it
down don't I oh okay all right well no
I'll take that as no then
um questions to the licensing officer
David have there been any requests from
the parties for permission to call
Witness
yes chair
yeah yeah and I will go through that now
for you to make determination whether
you accept those Witnesses or not or not
okay okay uh clarification
um
Tom Creswell for the applicant and I'll
just go through and then you can
determine at the end
um
Suffolk and stabbury obviously they will
have uh rubber foot I didn't don't have
Robert Farrow anymore they have Oliver
Williams
um
Environmental Protection have both James
Buckingham and Les King
okay
all right
um are we happy with that the Peter and
soon
is is uh Mr Ward being a witness for the
um uh premises yes I do I forgot that
one
apologies that he will be there to
answer questions if Mr dead needs him
too yes he's he's not a witness because
it's he's the premised license holder
but he'll be assisting you
yeah I'm representing him sorry yep
thank you
I don't I don't mean any disrespect
cancer
with me he's here next to me virtually
with his father
um and I'm taking instructions and I've
been keeping him abreast and any
questions you ask me if I don't know
myself because I've not got the
instruction I can revert to them lovely
okay Mr chairman thank you
licensing officer have have the parties
indicated they wish to present documents
or other material
yes and that has been disseminated to
the relevant party's concerned
right good right um applicant the
applicant uh Mr Creswell uh do you
estimate your time how long it will take
your presentation
um
I would say um am I am I allowed to
loudtronza after what was said
yes but as we said that we'll take that
as hearsay yes I I understand that
councilman Newman
um I would say no more than six or seven
minutes the whole lot including um my
sons
okay and uh the premises holder
um Mr dad's how long do you estimate
[Music]
um I would say probably about two hours
two hours
okay
um
Peter and uh Sue are we happy with this
uh yes I have no objection but I do
think both parties
um should be entitled to the same amount
of time so Joe can I interrupt yeah
David licensing officer can you ask the
same question to the responsible
authorities as well please
okay uh responsible authorities have
what sort of time would you expect
at least it'd be 20 minutes
okay in um Environmental Protection
I I hope that I can get through the
spoken part in 10 minutes
10 minutes and planning enforcement
officer
uh thank you chair yes I just need a
couple of minutes to go uh to summarize
the representation
okay so
um
Sarah and Peter are what about the two
hours from um well if it takes the hit
two hours it takes two hours uh we don't
have any control over that okay and can
I can I say Mr chairman I'm not going to
take any more time than it's necessary
I've had to estimate that time just in
case
um I've I've tried to
um put down my faults on that grid that
I sent around so hopefully I've got to
go through that I know that the other
parties will probably be about 50
minutes but it might be my two hours in
part is my representation and then
follow up by question so overall I will
be two hours so it might be broken down
thank you okay cheers right thank you
very much right we will now moved to the
hearing
um David Price would you like to present
the report please
so yeah I'm just getting off myself off
uh mute yeah okay so the officer summary
is as follows this hearing is determined
an application made through for the
review of a premises license made under
section 51 of the lighting act 2003 by
Borum gate East Road residence
Association in relation to the premises
of caffeine Lounge
Sudbury
the review application was received by
licing Authority on the 10th of August
2020 and a copy of this is attached to
the the officer report as appendix a in
summary the grounds for review are cited
by Resident Association as being that
the premises is associated with public
nuisance in respect of late night noise
between the hours of 2300 and 400 400
hours
and crime disorder involving antisocial
Behavior public urination fighting
drunken drunkenness damage to property
verbal abuse and continuous police and
ambulance call outs
the application was made for
has followed the standard review
procedure has been advertised as
required by regulation on the premises
on the council's website at the main
Council offices
on a noticeable
for not less than the relevant statutory
period which is in this sense since it's
28 days
the review application was served on the
premises license holder and responsible
authorities
in respective reviews the supper
committee is particularly referred to
section 11 of the Secretary of State
statutory guidance under Section 182 of
the lysing ACT section 22 of the
council's statement of the licensing
policy refers to review applications
in respect of decision making paragraph
11.2 of these Secretary of State's
guidance issued under Section 182 states
that in deciding which of these pairs to
invoke see 2.2 of the officers report
it is expected that the licing
authorities should so far as possible
seek to establish the cause or causes of
the concerns that the representations
identify
the remedial action taken should
generally be directed at these causes
and should always be no more than the
than appropriate and proportionate
response to addressing the causes of
concerns that instigate the review
the subcommittee will be aware of
considerations that I have set out in
the report at 7.6 in relation to public
nuisance anti-social Behavior planning
and licing regimes each case could
should be considered on its own merits
where revisions are made to legislation
or or guidance issued by the secular
State there may be a period of time when
the local statement of licing policy is
inconsistent with these revisions in
these circumstances The licing Authority
will have regard and give appropriate
weight to the relevant changes guidance
and its own statement of the licensing
policy
the subcommittee will also be aware of
Human Rights Act 1998 consideration
specifically article 6 1 and articles 8
and 1 of protocol one when dealing with
applications for review of existing
license without prejudice to any other
obligation imposed on it the local
Authority
will also be aware of its Duty under
Section 17 as a crime and disorder act
1998 when exercising its various
functions
representations the lasting Authority
has received three representations
from responsible authorities under the
licing act and these are attached to
this pending speed to this report
there have been four representations as
received by other persons in relation to
the application and these are attached
as appendix C to this report
the lasting Authority must reject
s and this is the council the account
the subcommittee's decision at 2.1
must reject the application for the
review unless it is relevant to at least
one of the four licing objectives and
these are crime disorder Public Safety
prevention of public relations and
protection in children from harm
and obviously 2.2 the office's report is
the subcommittee must have in regard to
the application an early reverent
representations
take such to the steps below if any as
it considers appropriate for the
promotions license objectives and the
steps are as follows
to modify the conditions as license
to exclude elicible activity from the
scope of the license
to remove the designated premises
supervisor to suspend the license for
appear not exceeding three months or
lastly to invoke the license
for these purposes conditions of the
license are modified if any of them are
altered or omitted or any new condition
is had added
where the authority takes a step
mentioned in 2.2 a or 2.2 B above it may
provide that the modification or
exclusion is to have a effect for only
such period of such period
any party agreed by the decision of the
licing authority in respect of this
application has a statutory right to
appeal to magistrates court and it's
those that are party to this hearing
any action taken by an icing Authority
via the review process would not take
effect until the time for bringing an
appeal has expired
and if an appeal is lodged until the
determination or withdraw of that appeal
and that includes the officer's report
okay thank you very much David right
have you got any um questions
for David
I can go around or you can put your
hands up if you wanna
any questions from anybody
no questions
okay all right there's no questions so
um uh the subcommittee yeah Sue what
have you got to ask took a while to get
the hand to work
um
it it may be that I have some questions
of the licensing officer that would be
more appropriate at a later Point
um can I therefore make those questions
later
yes certainly yeah thank you thank you
all right I'm Peter right lovely thank
you
all right no questions right well sorry
no chairman can I just can I just raise
up a point there if I may
yes David
yes thank you
um the both councils have indicated they
may have some questions of the licensing
officer the licensing officer is here
um undertaking a role I understand is
facilitating the report and the
representations an administrative
function
um any questions should in effect be at
this point in relation to the report if
there's any questions in his role as a
licensing officer well the licensing
Authority have not made representations
so they're not party to the proceedings
they're not a responsible Authority
making reps so I just want to just
double check that it's not questions
about the report or is it questions
about the premises conditions well that
will be that that that won't be
appropriate because they're not party to
the proceedings in that in that fashion
okay that Peter uh Peter Well thank you
Mr chairman well I'll put my question
now because I think most likely Mr Debs
does have a point
um it's on page eight of the report
um officer price
um little G and it's under the planning
planning and Licensing regime that's why
I thought I'd leave until later when the
planning officer might have spoke but
what is what is
um there that's uh wrong or or being
considered because I read that but it
doesn't tell me a reason why we should
or shouldn't do something
all right David right yeah it's there
for a point of clarification for um the
difference between both planning and
Licensing regimes
and neither obviously it's neither is
bound by each each of each decision so
if we make a decision planning is not
bound by our decision and neither is it
vice versa
but I thought you said in your uh
comments that
um that that they they were responsible
uh parties to this and there could be
views there that we could take on board
but
yes but they're not there are they or
will this come up later you were here
for me planning Authority a later stage
during the pro procedure so I can then
put my question at that point thank you
very much I've done my question to you
then thank you
so do you want to ask your question then
yes please chair it may be that
um I need legal advice as to whether
this is the right point to ask some
questions but given the nature of the
concerns that we are reviewing
um I wondered if someone could tell me
what conditions or concerns there are
um in terms of granting a license in
respect of noise that would be one
question and just for clarification
we shall be seeing
um evidence at a later point about the
precinct and so on and the shutting of
the gates and I would like to clarify
who is actually responsible for ensuring
that the precinct is closed at the
appropriate hour so it's really um
points of information I would just like
to clarify please
David Price can you come back with those
just the first point it's probably more
of a relevant question for Environmental
Protection Team so that would be a point
to to raise that question okay thank you
okay
uh locking up at the precinct
on the second Point locking up the
precinct Gates uh I'm told it's a
management company that the council has
instructed
okay
okay so happy with that yes yes thank
you
okay
shall I put my question at a later point
about the um in respect of noise when
the environmental yeah that'd be great
thank you uh max Mr chairman sorry
um
sorry to interrupt can I follow on from
what Sue's just asked in the answer of
course you can yeah
officer Pro scare you
um he said it's in a management company
by baber District Council that closes
the gates do we have times do we know
um you know will we have more
information on this because this is one
one of the fundamental uh areas of
dispute
um so uh to say it's uh baby council's
management committee I mean who are they
do they turn up at a certain time uh
have we heard from them
District Council is the land owner so
the land owner of um gate
shopping pressing
so we are the council is the um the
landowner there uh the management
company that is instructed by baby
District count labor District Council to
close those Gates and the gates I'm told
are shut around 11 o'clock in the
evening
thank you thank you Mr chairman all
right okay right no more questions right
we'll move on to the applicant to
present his case uh Trevor Creswell
would you like to present your case
please
right
good morning everybody
um good morning I'm gonna read that
statement that my son wrote before he
had to shoot back to work this morning
sorry to interrupt Mr chairman but we're
just getting the top of his head that's
better sorry Peter is that there thank
you thank you very much
okay and I'm also trying to read this uh
piece of paper right go right here we go
Peter uh since the caffeine Lounge
opened
live in a forum gate has affected my
life in a big way I sleep on the
roadside which is great eastern
I have been woken all hours of the night
from 11 p.m till 4 a.m people shouting
swearing and witnessing fighting even a
man exposing himself
uh people being sick and urinating
against Park cars underneath my bedroom
window for many months I ignored this
then one weekend my children Came To
Stay the noise was so bad that I had to
ask Dad to let them have the bedroom in
the precinct Precinct side
so they can escape the noise while Dad
had to go down and sleep on the sofa
um
I took it upon myself to buy a CCTV
camera
but it was a fake one that I bought from
lawyers this upset Mr Ward
um and he confronted me when I went out
to walk the dog
um
he called me uh
pedophile announced saying that I was
taking photos of children
um
I'd like to interject please and make a
point of order
yeah absolutely with the legal advisor
in accordance with the
um statutory guidance section 182 a
paragraph 11 9. it makes it clear that a
witness or a party to the proceedings
May amplify amplify the original
representation that they're hearing but
in relation to amplification let me just
read it out it says representations must
be made in writing and may be Amplified
at the subsequent hearing or standing
their own rights additional
representations that do not amount to an
amplification is the original
representations may but not be made at
the hearing representations may be made
electronically provided to the license
Authority agrees
etc etc I can say to you absolutely now
I've not had a copy of that statement
it's an it has not been made before
about an allegation Mr Ward making those
comments uh it's not been put into
writing that I understand and it would
be disputed in in my instructions it's a
statement that I've not had it's more
than an amplification it's a new
representation and should be excluded
legal advisor David
well we've all do you expect we don't we
don't know what the original
representations were and whether what
sort of amplification we have
um we do it's on the application
excuse me could I please speak I I
actually have a crime a Suffolk crime
number here because this was ranging
when people came to our door and
threatened my son
we were given the number by the police
when Mr chairman this is completely
inappropriate that I've made I've made a
legal point that needs to be addressed
because you're hearing information now
that should be not being included
because it's not been given to us in
advance the representation the
application is made out of page 11 to
page 18. that is the representation by
the residents Association they have
called Tom Thomas Cresswell as a witness
to speak to that application as the
guidance says that you should be in
writing it is in writing and it stands
in its own right but additional
representations can amplify this but no
new representations must be made
otherwise it prejudices me because it's
the first time I'm hearing it I should
be able an opportunity to have it in
advance and prepare that is why the
statutory guidance says that those
representations cannot be and must not
be made at the hearing
all right Trevor hold on a moment legal
advisor
David I don't know what original
representations were made
um I'm aware that uh Mr Thomas Creswell
was due to being making representations
with regards to his experience of being
a residence close to the license
premises I don't know what specifics
were put into the original attendance at
hearing form and clearly so far as
amplification is concerned therefore we
can't say how much is amplification and
what is new
um I'm just wondering whether Mr Trevor
Crest will can confirm how much more of
the statement there is to be read out
because clearly it is still a hearsay
statement
uh there's not much more of the
statement to read out
um I I
um I guess there's about another two
minutes or a minute of statement and and
that is it
okay can you hold on a moment I think
Sue Carpenter what do you want to say
Sir um I just yes again to clarify uh
from a procedure point of view
um I was recognizing some of the
language that Mr Trevor Creswell has
just used in reading out and I seem to
find that on page 15 of the agenda so
whilst um the person who wrote it unless
it was Mr Trevor Creswell
um we may not be able to ask questions
if if uh if this in fact is from Tom
Creswell but we do have all this
information uh on pages
um 14 15 and 16. so it's not new and it
should have been available to everyone I
would just appreciate some advice on
what what attention we can pay to that
thank you
please comment Mr chairman yeah can I
just hear Peter beer first he was up
there for you Peter thank you well just
to support uh uh councilor carpental
entirely because that was the point I
was going to make we do have these
papers and comments in front of us and I
would just perhaps suggest to Mr Trevor
Creswell that he he chooses his words
very carefully and not ad fins because
we have got this in front of us and that
may not inflame the situation quite as
much then
thank you uh Mr chairman firstly I I
don't like I don't do it lightly but I
disagree with the legal advisor the the
representations are in effect the
application made which is in your pack
and as counselor Carpenter said it is
there before you
um any and any new representation over
and above here cannot be included so
whether he is here in person or reading
a statement any new statement could not
be added today and in relation to the
council's comment it is right that it
says almost so it says teenagers leaving
the cafe Lounge shouting pedo as they
walk past now that he said in the papers
but what we've heard this morning is
that Mr Ward did that and I object to
that statement being made because we
object to that so I'm saying that that
is additional representation that I've
not heard before I'm not seen anyone
writing and I'm right to raise it now
because it should have been done in
advance and it's a new statement so I am
correct I believe in saying that that
was a new statement and should not be
included in today's and should be
excluded
um and obviously I will deal with the
other issues regarding what other
teenagers have led alleged to have said
or not said
all right okay thank you um I think
David Price did you have your hand up
I did for a moment chair
um clarification for the committee if I
may yeah
obviously part of what um uh Mr
creswell's statement is is not new
evidence obviously if Mr Creswell wishes
to withdraw the the name Ward with that
with that appreciate for the license
holder
uh Trevor could you do that
we draw that
I just say this Mark
um what I would say
I did not say that um
not being rude Mr Ward came down the
road and said those words all came up to
up to the roof and did it like
individuals did I said you confronted my
son and said certain things near his
premises but I if it's a problem I'll
withdraw it but if you could please yes
can you withdraw that I'll withdraw it
thank you Trevor can you carry on with
your report then please Trevor I will do
yeah yeah thank you
you carry on now
um anyway
he said so it carries on I was
threatened at my own house by
individuals being called names I won't
use names but we know the names
um
no Mr chairman we I must object again
and we we just had the withdrawal of the
name he's saying
and I I do strongly object and a
statement being read out in hearsay on
behalf of the party did not make
representation in 28 days who has now
been told is a uh joining the hearing as
a resident of the association is making
a statement read out that he's not
consistent with the representation made
and is against the statutory guidance
says it's a new representation made now
if that that's going to continue then
um I obviously I object strongly saying
that that should not be included Mr wall
did not say that and we don't accept
that
okay thank you hold on Trevor uh legal
advisor David
yes um we've been alerted to the page of
the application page 15 which deals with
this particular point I wonder whether
it would be appropriate for Mr Creswell
to see that specific page I think it I
think it is a an appropriate Point
that's made by Mr dad on behalf of the
license holder with regards to
amplification and I think also there are
some very valid points that are made by
Council De Beer but it may be that if Mr
Cresswell can see what was originally
within the
um representations that were made in the
application it may be that certain
things do not and should not be added to
so I think that may be a fair way uh for
this particular aspect to be dealt with
okay thank you David okay Trevor is that
agreeable
can you choose your words a bit more
carefully
thank you carry on then I know
yeah
um
yeah so he's carried on and he's put
so for the lot since July
um
right up to the um September and uh when
the when the law changed and and places
shut early it's been a very difficult
place to live
um quite an intimidating place in at
night
um and I don't feel that
um
that they are
uh what she's put on there I'm trying to
read it they are appropriate people to
have a a late night drinking license uh
regards uh Tom Creswell
okay and then have you got anything else
to say for yourself or yeah I have and
and to be honest I I I I can do this um
without a uh piece of paper
um I I will be honest with you I I went
to the uh
when uh the Catherine Lounge open I went
tried to go to the the plan and at the
very start
um I think it opened November December
last year
Trevor can I just stop you there one
second a David legal wants to say Frank
David
apologies it's a historic hand I've
taken it down ah okay sorry Trevor to
keep stopping you carry on anyway I I
went to the original Planet now I I I'm
not going to lie no this I I had issues
my main issue was I was concerned that
we were going to have late night drink
and lots of disturbance and I know I
live in the Town Center I understand
that fully now when the place opened
I had a lot of noise I'm gonna be honest
within the precinct the precinct was
never shut
it was never shut it was open till four
in the morning
it didn't shut at 11. it was always
inside the precinct it was like the
inside of a football ground it Echo as
you people who know Sudbury like Peter
may know and Mark might know the
precinct has a canopy that goes around
it and the noise in there it was was bad
come January I had words William I tried
to sort it in a man-like fashion so we
could resolve it it didn't work caused
me a lot of grief I wish I hadn't
bothered
and then obviously we had the lockdown
we had the Coronavirus
and it opened on the 4th of July
all the nightclubs were shut
the pubs
on the 4th of July everything opened the
pubs but the nightclub was shut
all the bars were shutting at 11 or 12.
everyone was coming down to the cafe and
lounge
the Catherine Lounge wasn't as you'll
see on the police report on the photos I
took
that didn't look like don't I'm not
being judgmental there was many gamers
going to the Catherine Lounge
definitely was a different clientele
the late night drinking spilled into the
street
the noise has been horrendous
there has been lots of incidents as you
will see yourselves by the police report
and this was ongoing
now this didn't really stop probably
this went on for two months I spoke to
the police they put a camera up I
appreciate it but it's probably too late
because by then
things were dying off a bit and the 10
o'clock curfew coming obviously once
that come in there was no one there
people were going there obviously late
night drinking now
there was no Infinity
but it was
said Put it mildly it was like living in
magaloof in August living here you
couldn't sleep and this wasn't Friday
and a Saturday night this was for
possibly five nights a week
the police
spent lots and lots of time in this area
the ambulance turned up on numerous
occasions
I know what's going on there I'm talking
as an individual whatever Mr dads might
say about me being a cancer I am talking
about a person who lives 50 yards from
the caffeine Lounge I saw I took photos
I took videos
I had proof
everywhere when I read the police report
that police report backed up everything
I said now
the police
that there was times that they didn't
come out they weren't called but there
was still incidents that that is only
what you know about that is not the ones
that you don't know about and you can
dress up how you like you can have after
this we can have nice charity things and
it might look lovely at three o'clock in
the afternoon
but I would say to anybody
between 11 and 3 it's been a different
animal
so my view is
65 of his
times the police have been there has
been after 11 P.M
that means 35 times 35 have been between
when he opened and 11 pm
in my estimation that was 14 or 15 times
the police then came during the day and
that tells me
that is meant to be a place for children
to go and game that tells me they're not
sitting proper
I have also
crime numbers from me and my son and
from Sally Jay from Richards where
she was
told to leave things alone in a matter
of speaking and she contacted the police
about Behavior the owner
he has been an ongoing saga
and it is
it's changed their lives dramatically
and
Flawless covered
I wouldn't wish it on anybody in the
world but that has give us some peace
and some quiet and life shouldn't be
like that should it I I I expect we got
maybe 20 30 pubs and suffering and I
would say that between them they've had
less visits in the caffeine Lounge has
in the last six months between them and
that tells you everything
okay thank you very much for listening
uh thank you Trevor Creswell thank you
very much right um have we got any
questions for Trevor
uh Sue carpentel
thank you chairman
um just two or three questions please to
uh Trevor Creswell
um if I can ask you
just to confirm for me um you made a
comment about a fake CCTV camera am I
correct that it was fake and not a real
one
sorry I was on mood yes yes sir so what
what was your what was your rationale
for getting a fake to CCTV camera
um
because well my son bought it what it
was
um my son
um
uh hassle he put something on Facebook I
believe and this was the time when I
told you
Mr Ward um
had uh took umbrage with it didn't like
it so my son came home and said
I am going to put a camera
so he put a camera up as to say because
all the hassle what was going on outside
airport urinating the fighting
so you put a camera up but it was a
false one and I believe Sudbury police
would confirm that
um because
we we rank later on when that went up we
then we start getting more abuse
um
from from uh people leaving the caffeine
Lounge coming up our stairs
um
so we um
we we ran the police to complain about
um the the threats that were being given
um and they looked at the camera
um and and they could see that it was a
seven pound one from Roy's and it wasn't
even wired up but it was more as a
deterrent of what was going on outside
of our property
um
that that's one question thank you
um if I can refer you to page 16 of the
agenda pack
um we're talking about all sorts of
people shouting
um I wasn't quite clear about who was
shouting was this just people in the
street or in the precinct or where where
were they
well I'm not asking you to to give us
any names but um no no I mean to be
honest uh
between between uh November December
sort of March time the first time is
open most of the noise I'm going to be
honest was within the precinct it was
never shut but when it opened to
um when it reopened on the 4th of July
most of the noise there was some noise
in the precinct but the noise generally
was coming from the Great Eastern
roadside uh which is the same side as
always of rocksham
um and and the alleyway behind
which was being used for many other
activities
um and the noise was in those areas it
was absolutely horrendous yes
so really we're perhaps talking about
the difference between winter and summer
here
well I I think what we're talking about
um being honest is is that in July uh
the venue the Catherine Lounge was the
only place open in Sudbury uh perhaps
after uh 12 p.m and there was a loophole
there because the nightclub was shut and
everyone was converging on uh the
caffeine lounge and without being
disrespectful they were making the best
of her of a situation and um what we
were doing then obviously people were
already coming down
um
half cut if you want to put it and um
obviously uh we're drinking two three
four in the morning
um and and sometimes the doors uh staff
would be seen leaving at five so um
maybe later so
so when you're talking about people
arriving being it's your observation
that was your yes depression that was
your impression oh without a doubt yes
definitely yes okay
um are you submitted a number of
photographs and videos and I wonder if
uh without taking us all the way through
them if you could just explain uh why
you submitted some of these uh there are
several for example of an empty but lit
Precinct
yes because I was trying to show that
the precinct never shut it 11 like
when it opened the precinct was meant to
open uh shut at 11 and the the the uh
the entrance would have been from Great
Eastern Road that was her thing with
Bob's traded for 15 or 20 years but the
precinct was shut so there'll be no
noise or damage within the precinct and
I was trying to show that that didn't
shut at 11 PM and the shutting of the
precinct is actually down to the
management company
well so I believe
yeah but that wasn't happening and uh
even now it's not consistent done at a
consistent time
okay
um those are my questions for now thank
you chairman no no worries
thank you uh did you have one po or not
yes yes I've got about four
um
sorry counselor sorry counselor can I
interject
um stick to procedure can you go to the
um premises license holder first please
sorry and then we'll come back okay yeah
sorry okay yep yep sorry okay
um yeah yeah I think I can well I've
written down so I'll get back yeah David
dads would you like to come in
yes I'm gonna have to uh just ask for a
very short
um five ten minute a German and comfort
break I need to speak to the client
about some of the representations made
these are new they're not so they're not
they're an amplification I didn't stop
the uh uh travel Crest World during the
um last bit because I thought I'd
already made the point clear on making
submissions but can I have 5-10 minutes
short Comfort break but also to get some
instructions for my clients so I can ask
some questions of Trevor Cresswell
a point of clarification or order
um I didn't know whether it would be
possible to put my questions because
that might help Mr Debs
um if he wanted to question anything
from his client
um but if if you think I should wait
until after was them fair enough but
they are relevant to what counselor
sorry what Mr Trevor Creswell has
actually said yes I'm not worried what
order it is personally myself well it
just might be
we'll let Peter have a speak and then
we'll just do a few questions and then I
think we'll adjourned for half an hour
for lunch and that gives everyone a bit
of time to sort out things yeah yeah
because he he might pick up a couple of
the points
um
following on from this fake CCTV uh Mr
Trevor Creswell
um
you said that it didn't work and what
have you but I seem to remember seeing a
video which I assume is a CTV or a
camera fan where you you and I assume
I'm sure I'm right that you were
actually filming in the early hours of
the morning and commenting and there's a
group of
um uh uh people walking in the
um Precinct
um and but they weren't actually going
into the premises and I think you were
trying to show show the point of view
that they were making a bit of noise and
that the the doors were open
um so you did have a camera of some
description at some point filming some
of this is that correct
can't hear you
Trevor would you like to put your mic on
yeah I've just done it sorry it was just
my phone Peter that was your phone right
yes yeah that's that's fine that's
cleared that point up so there was there
and you was showing that uh now the
other thing was that you you you made
the point two or three times that it was
never shut what do you mean was never
shut over the doors to the lounge or the
gates to the precinct
um at the time um before before the uh
March lock deck lockdown I believe it's
March I would say oh I'd say all three
doors within the precinct uh the one
from um comes from uh where the kiosk is
uh the ones where the uh from Great
Eastern Road where the wheelie bins are
and the one nose into the bus stop all
were open and so were the caffeine
Lounge doors
I have had his inside door shut
obviously for the heat but the outer
doors would have been
opened my photos
thank you and
um did you ever complain to baber
District Council management committee
who operate these
um Gates on the outside not the doors to
the lanes but the gates
I believe I I wrote I believe I wrote to
the council yes and I also probably I'm
90 certain can't remember I went back to
the um to the town hall about it to the
to the club at the Town Hall yes I would
have done that yes definitely I don't
know what the clout to the town hall
ahead with it but anyway thank you for
that I would have gone to the council at
Subway as well oh I see right thank you
I got your point
um now
you refer to Malaga or something the
news that I've never been there so I
don't know uh but
um from what you're saying
it it your quality of life has been
badly affected by this premises and the
goings on as you see them or as they've
been relayed or going to be related to
us and lack of sleep
um
and you consider this to be unreasonable
I mean we're all entitled to a good
night's sleep we're all entitled to
um quality of life but
I didn't get the impression from you
whether that affected your quality of
life you you you did State the problems
no very much so I I would say I was very
I am very fortunate uh counselor
um
that I I sort of don't have to get up in
the morning go out the door at seven
o'clock like some people do I do work
but I I work in a different way but
um people up here I I reckon I was woken
certainly from July four to five nights
a week
sometimes it
might the noise might be 15 minutes but
it would keep you awake because you've
been woken you just go back and it would
happen again so you might get the first
noise at midnight it might go on for 20
minutes and then you'd have another
no ways again at half past two and that
might go on for half an hour
my my son was working in London at the
time he's changed job
um and he was having to drive down to
London and some nights he hardly had any
sleep it was absolutely and it was
horrendous I can't put it any other way
and uh it was Mega Loof Peter in English
thank you my last question Mr chairman
was uh to you Mr kurswell
um
did you presumably at the beginning but
had you had reasonable relations with
the
um the owner of the operator of the
um lounge and that could you talk quite
a bit or had this broken down very early
on
the proprietor you mean Peter yes yeah
don't kill
if that's okay Mr dance I will use it
his name is William
um right oh first of all um I believe
that William felt
um that I had something personal against
him I would like to say that was not
true that is utter the garbage is the
only word I can use because I came over
to the planning at the start and my well
is my concerns was about what what has
gone on about noise and disturbance
wasn't about the nature of the business
now
in January
I went to see Mr Ward I'd been woken up
three nights
and one Saturday morning uh I think it
was the fourth of January I went to see
Mr wood
I went inside the precinct to start
which was at the time was he claimed his
main door
and I could see people I know no one
answered it's about 11 o'clock I'm just
guessing we are talking January
and no one answered the door so I won
but I saw people in so I walked round
the door was unlocked and I walked I
knocked on the door walked in and I
spoke to his bar manager
Mr Lorenzo all on video
and I asked to speak to William now the
conversation
about my lack of sleep and why the
precinct wasn't being shut at 11 PM
now it was all going well until I
mentioned why isn't the precinct
shutting at 11 P.M
and I tried to explain to him my
neighbors young children
you're going to get someone
suffer and they're going to come down to
see I'm not threatening him in a violent
way I'm trying to say where things lead
if you don't try and get your house in
order and sort things out people up here
were having horrendous night's sleep
so he asked me to leave and I did I
never moved my arms about I never
sheltered I walked away the next thing I
have the police speak to me now I'm
going to be honest with you I did
nothing and I wasn't
the Town Council and I I know I had to
suffer all that
all because
Mr ward in my opinion thinks he's Above
the Law thinks he can do what he like
and this is still ongoing now Peter two
nights ago Mr dorton
lives above the caffeine Lounge there
was noise in there we're meant to be in
covert and it's meant to be shut so
there you go I'm sorry but that's how I
feel and I'm really disappointed how
things are
a lot but but it's not personal
thank you thank you can just uh an
additional question of what you've just
said you referred again
uh and it's come through and it's one of
the big argument points I think that
um the the gates weren't shut
in your opinion do you feel that was the
proprietor's responsibility to shut the
gates or be able to cancel because it's
coming through very clearly to me that
this is the responsibility of the
management committee management team of
baby District Council outside the
control of Mr Wards uh yes of Mr Wards
so
um do you agree there or not
oh I I do now and and um I'm gonna be
honest um
since July whatever since I opened the
second time after the covert uh the
precinct
that they've not been consistent with
time but they have that has been locked
up Peter but so that's not the
proprietor's fault that's what you're
saying well I don't know whose
responsibility it was in November but uh
we're told with respect that it's Baba
District Council management
um
um people that are responsible anyway
Peter I'll just come in there quickly
Peter um baby District Council employ a
management company to lock up the
precinct and clean it and they could
even live in Chelmsford Ipswich or
anywhere but we get a company to come in
so obviously we've got to check this
company's doing their job but let that
all be noted in this hearing but that's
by paint and Mr Creswell where he's
referring and
um with respect to him
um he blames or points the finger to
boards the proprietor of the premises
here uh because he perhaps he didn't
know any different at that time but it's
being made clear and coming out loud and
clear to me now that it is the
responsibility of baby District Council
management committee not the
responsibility of the
um Cafe Lounge
at some point
okay yeah yep
sorry what I would turn around and say
you now reference the gates and the
shutters the caffeine Lounge worth
something when they wanted in January
and they did have a set of keys so they
were shutting them I I don't know whose
obligation it was and I might not be
quite right but they were shutting them
when they chose to
and they had keys well we'll try and get
that plant clarified Mr chair okay with
that
yeah I've got Chris Cornish waiting to
speak Chris I've got a question I'll
just clarify um councilor beers
questioning there
um my understanding is from our
investigation into the allegations made
is that there was a defect in one of the
roller doors that couldn't be shut and
it was not being shut it was not being
managed by the management company the
management company and security firm
were employed later on I believe around
March
just before the covid and my
understanding is it is entirely
responsibility since covid of the
management company to shut over able to
shut the doors my question
so Mr Creswell is
when the doors are closed do you still
have occasions where you are disturbed
by noise from customers of the caffeine
Lounge in the precinct despite the doors
being closed
yes but not as often um Mr Cornish um
used to be regular but uh yes there are
occasions where
um not not obviously recently with the
10 o'clock but before the 10 o'clock yes
until three o'clock yes but not not
since the 10 o'clock perfume and uh
obviously that changed everything
okay thank you and just just clarify our
Council appear as well the the
use of the external doors the precinct
um and the use of the doors into the
precinct from the Catherine Lounge are
separate issues the planning permission
has a condition that prevents those
doors being used regardless of whether
the external doors to the precincts are
an issue obviously you will have passer
buyers and Wanderers through the
precinct that could be unopposed if the
roller shuttle goes which is obviously
nothing to do with caffeine Lounge it
exacerbates the situation thank you all
right thank you
right is any more questions for anyone
Chad do you want to go to
um Suffolk and stabbury and also the
planning authority to see whether they
have any questions and then Mr chairman
isn't it that I should be asking
questions but we um I thought you said
that you would allow Council of beer to
ask of these questions and then we would
break because I obviously need to ask my
questions
um and I think I've I ought to be sort
of giving that opportunity following the
procedures
yeah great
a great pay it yet so what we'll do is
we're we're adjourning meeting for half
an hour so we'll say we're open start
again at quarter past one is that okay
with everyone
David yep no my hand's taken down
good okay okay so we'll have um half
hour break we're reconvene at quarter
past one yeah thank you
okay
thank you Mr chairman
um it's now 1323 we've broke for lunch
before lunch we had uh Mr Trevor
Creswell uh making uh finals or making
submissions on behalf of the applicant
um so far as the next stage is concerned
there will be questions on behalf of the
license holder followed by questions
from responsible authorities then other
persons and then uh the licensing
officer
so I think therefore it's Mr dad sir
yes sir thank you very much
um if uh with your permission
um Mr chairman can I start just to ask
some points questions of clarification
of uh uh Trevor Creswell
yeah okay thank you
um
Mr Cresswell Council Creswell
um the um and you just confirmed for me
that the application at page 11 through
to
18 is your application on behalf of a
residence Association
yes I can confirm that
are you able to put your camera on so I
can see you
I can do
a lot thank you
um if you um look at page 18
um that is in the agenda that's your
signature
and having a new suit have you have you
got that in front of you
yeah
when you see that it's your signature it
that is your signature is that right
that is correct yeah and can you see
above it says it is an offense under
section 15a of the licensing act to make
a false statement in connection with
this application you can see it there
and you mustn't make ineffective false
application a statement
do you understand that well I do
understand it yeah uh so can I just ask
you to confirm that then everything can
be here did you from on on let me just
turn up to page I think it's in the
agenda because I think gender page 14.
um
the the the information to support the
application that's on page 14 and it
goes all the way to where it's signed
Again by you a page 16. can you see that
no not really
I might say the writing um it goes over
the page you can't quite see it but it
is on page 14 after page 13.
and it begins with since opening on the
4th of July can you see that yes I can
now see that yes yeah yes and if you if
you turn up to the next page and the
following page page 16
um it says kind regards Trevor Cresswell
um and it and it appears that that's
that that's your that's your evidence in
support is that right
yes I would say that's roughly right yes
no is it roughly right or is it right is
that your signature and is that your um
evidence in support yes it is
now is there anything in there that you
wish to correct now or amend or do you
or are you saying that that is all
correct
um if you give me two minutes Mr dead so
I'll come back to you
foreign
where it starts setting out the dates
say for example you know it starts the
4th of July and then it's 12 for July 19
24 26. can you see those days is that
your handwriting is that your all your
information no one else is it's your
information your facts and knowledge
says on there Mr dad's if you look like
the 26th of July uh the video was taken
by my son and that's got his name there
underneath on the bottom one at four a.m
in the morning yeah on the 26th of July
it says Tom the ones where they probably
don't say anybody on me
that was by Tom on the Saturday at 11 24
because I put his name next to it
okay so what you're saying to the
committee and as I understand it is that
and thank you for clarifying it's very
useful is that we're um there's a name
next to it like Tom that that's Tom's
information you're relying on and where
there's no name it is you
I would say yes
thank you and before I ask you any
further questions about those grounds
I'd just like to ask some general uh
questions first is that
um have you have you made a formal
complaint to the environmental health
department for enforcement at the local
Council
I believe so yes I believe so uh have
they
um have they
um told you that when you make a
complaint uh there is a process in which
the council takes any members of public
and particularly you being a counselor
um would would I would I would hope that
they would follow their own procedure
take you through steps on how to make
your complaint and how to report noise
nuisance have they done that for you the
officers
how to go around making a complaint yes
okay
thank you so
um have they provided you with log
sheets to record the details of the
noise the dates and times
yes
have you completed those logs and
returned them to the council I did
complete some of those logs and I did I
did reset I did send them back yes
but they don't appear in the agenda do
they
I will send back
I I I I I I I've not questioned you on
that and talk clarification I'm just
asking that you've completed log sheets
recording dates times sent some of those
to the local Authority but they haven't
you don't see them in the in the agenda
no
um
have you had any officers visit your
home and particularly the bedroom of a
night time to do any monitoring of sound
I install noise monitoring equipment in
your bedroom there has been no
monitoring sound in my house
foreign
points just perhaps just to clarify
um you've not provided any evidence of
the residence Association membership
have you
and how would that be produced
well you you haven't provided any
details of names whose how many members
or anything like that have you I have I
when I originally we formed the resident
group I sent in a form with everybody's
address and the people who were in the
group on that form when it was signed
for their addresses
okay but that doesn't appear in the
agenda no
not in this pack no
well would that be a question for maybe
Mr Price later or
um then in relation to
um
the alleged issues that you complain of
it's fair to say
uh that inside the premises so
physically inside what goes on inside
you've not made any complaints of
personally no
and uh is this is a general point just
to sort of try to get down to the issues
outside there's the precinct area
which is I will call the precinct area
and then there's the outside to Great
Eastern Road So Great Eastern Road there
are two distinct areas where that
um there are matters complained of in
your application is that right
that's correct
now in relation to the precinct
um and I don't want to put words into
your mouth but in essence you're saying
now
pretty much because it's being locked up
there are a few all not so many
complaints regarding the precinct area
is that right
I would say that that is a fair thing to
say
[Music]
obviously when it premises were open to
a three but was still not as often
but there were still people
coming out the premises
on occasions and there was noise but
obviously when the place shut at 10
there was no noise after a period after
because there was nobody
but so it's fair enough to say that it's
fair enough to say if if the landlord
I'll just say the landlord
organizes themselves to close the
the precinct
and the premises
does not allow egress into the precinct
that resolves the issue of any noise
arising in the precinct from your point
of view
yes it does it does
um I I have it does
um but
I've been informed by the manager of the
precinct this morning that two members
of staff from the caffeine Lounge were
outside within the precinct at four a.m
this morning why they were in there
with covert and that was this morning
so okay well well I'll cover that
um later that's the first time I've
heard it but I'll take instructions but
thank you I I wanted to ask about the
the precinct and you've answered that
and I'll cover uh I'll carry on if I
know Jim is that all right
say something
when well if I can ask if I the the at
the moment unless the chairman stops me
I I I'm asking you some questions you I
asked the question you've answered it
and I'd like to move to my next question
if I may go on then
outside
Great Eastern Road yes there are
complaints made uh in your grounds for
representation
for
disturbances outside in the public place
that's correct isn't it
and that's correct
in relation to
um where you sleep not to be personal
but I think it's a matter of public
record
um you're where you retire to bed in
your bedroom is the precinct side that
that faces the precinct is that right
that is correct
and is it fair to say that matters are
rising in Great Eastern Street do not
affect you your sleep if you sleep in
that bedroom facing the precinct
no that's not fair
um to say that the noise when the
premise was open till three it felt like
well I've got up in the night
felt like it it was so loud it felt like
it was outside my window so no even
though I was on the precinct side the
noise was still horrendous and you could
hear it through the flat not just on the
Great Eastern Road no
okay so you're saying that noise from
Great Eastern Road is heard all the way
through the flat to your bedroom that
faces the precinct
yes I am yes okay
um
you'll have to in the summertime
as people have to appreciate
when it's 90 degrees we all want a bit
of air
and to have a bit of air it's it's a
catch-22
if you want a bit of air you can't have
your windows undone because of the noise
well that this that side of it as well
so you completed your logs
during the summer and log down those
noise complaints in your log which you
filed with the council yes
yes I believe I did yes
when you say I believe I did you did you
did thank you so in relation to
um
my next question just generally to just
get down to the issues before covid yes
before the the March
you are in your evidence you've given
you appear to be mainly dealing with
issues arising in the precinct not in
Great Eastern Road is that right
that is correct and
um it appears to be now since
um post covered or we are in covid since
July when the premises reopened you
believe that there are
um noise complaints uh predominantly
arising from Great Eastern Road is that
right
yes definitely on the main yes okay I
just wanted to summarize that as a an
understanding of your your evidence at
the moment I don't I just want to take
you now
to some um back to page
um 14 if I may
[Music]
14. yep
now
that's page 14 members of the agenda
[Music]
Mr Chris flow if you got that okay
yes I have yes okay
yes so I'm going to now ask you some
questions about this this this
um this written submission
um do you accept
that people Great Eastern Road come from
various sources they can just be members
of the public walking by do you accept
that
not entirely no
so do you not accept that there may be
members of the public using Great
Eastern Road
that are unconnected with my clients
premises
one would no why I say that that is 2 am
there aren't there wasn't any places
open for anyone to be only your clients
well do you accept that members of the
public may be visiting each other and
just maybe passing through Great Eastern
Road there may be other reasons why
people are on Great Eastern Road other
than visiting license premises I would
say there's a 10 chance one in 10 maybe
visiting but nine out of ten weren't
going or leaving the establishment so
your your answer is slightly different
now you're saying that you're except
that maybe 10 of people using Great
Eastern Road are not connected to our
services I'm not saying they're not I'm
sending may not be
okay
now minority
in relation to
um
[Music]
what you've written now on the 26th of
July I'm just gonna pull out a couple of
these that I just want to look at if I
may could you possibly just put the
camera down so I can see you it'll be
it'd be very helpful you might find it
helpful if you just rest the phone or
the tablet and it might steady steady a
bit
all right thank you now in relation to
um the 26th of July you see here you say
26th of July
a video outside
um allow uh 23 minutes past please at
the caffeine Lounge 27 minutes past
drunks leaving cafes Down video
315 fight leaving uh caffeine Lounge
video
a three o'clock fight outside caffeine
Lounge yet Tom's camera yep
um and in four o'clock ambulance all
right do you see all that
I do
yeah and did you are you saying to the
committee that you witnessed at 3 15 as
written here a fire outside caffeine
Lounge
I am saying
[Music]
yes I am saying there would have been
the scuffle there would have been
policing probably police involved that's
why an ambulance is there later on yes I
I I I can't say it's right outside their
door but it's in that area yes I would
say so and I would say I've still got
the videos if required well I'm asking
I'm asking a specific question in
relation to fights leaving I'm saying
did you witness yourself a fight at 3 15
on the 26th of July as you've written
here it's your evidence
would say yes
it's not on your camera caffeine Lounge
is where we go with this I would say yes
so you're trying to
do you want me to pause
um uh sorry one Mr Smith would you like
me to uh pause for a moment
um I've just been Mindful and ask people
to be mindful as I was reminded this
morning that we're not here to
cross-examine
um I know there's a thin line between
getting information and cross-examining
cross-examining I just make an
observation at the moment let's just
steer clear of cross-examination if we
can I I I'm I'm certainly not
cross-examining I'm I'm just clarifying
the position of the evidence and I'm
seeking to challenge the evidence in
which you're now just about to hear but
and I think it is right that I do say
um May I continue I don't want to upset
anyone I hope you don't mind I'm saying
that with respect I'm trying to avoid
that I'm not I'm not putting questions
as a cross-examination uh that I would
these are open questions and I've
allowed
allowed it in that way so that I'm not
cross-examining
is that all right um sir
okay well carry on thank you
so
um what you just said to the committee
was I think you're trying to anticipate
my next question my next point you said
well it may not have been directly
outside because I don't know what the
cameras would have shown yes so you're
trying to anticipate what I'm maybe
going to say
well actually
um the police provided
um their Chris and Cat reports
um and members you have got the Chris
and Cadbury ports provided by the police
now I don't know if they were
distributed to everyone
um now I what I've done just so that um
we could perhaps just at this point just
clarify how we've got it now I've
completed a schedule for everyone you
will see
sorry the reason I oops sorry I'm gonna
have to stop you there yes you're great
you're going into
um official sensitive data and I'm gonna
need to stop you sorry
it's only for the police sorry no I'm
I'm not uh I'm not referring to any
particular data at the moment or we're
going to part two uh but at the moment
I'm not revealing any names or any any
specifics but I'm quite happy Miss
Germany if you think that there's a
danger of going into part two then I
make an application that we're going to
part two
David Price what do you think
yes Jay if if um if the Mr dad's wishes
to speak about confidential information
then we need to go into private session
yes then may I make that application
please
um Mr chairman on a point of order
um I think the uh Mr dubs made it clear
that he wasn't mentioned any names or
referring to any persons
um so do we need to go into
confidentiality at this point uh if he's
not divulging anything
um surely it would be better in the
public domain at this stage
I I think so too and and I'm not I'm
only probably no more referring to what
the police have written in their
representations there's not going to be
any Revelations
okay I just checked with David legal
David what do you think
one moment David legal
so I I don't know what specifics are
going to be referred to by Mr dad
clearly if if anything can be identified
that really would have been dealt with
in private session then we need to go
into private session
if no details are provided from the cad
information which is officially
sensitive then we can proceed in public
okay but it's a it's a rightful concern
that's been raised so I I have to leave
it
yeah and I will be very careful sir
okay if David uh legal with if you think
he's uh going into a dangerous area can
you say Obviously and stop stop him
going well I think I think we're relate
we're going to an issue of the 26th of
July would that be correct Mr dad's yes
yeah
so if you can ask your questions without
divulging information that's in that
sense
um
so uh
Mr principal coming back we've been
provided with the crossing cab reports
now I members have provided to everyone
a grid of those events which set out the
cab reference the date time description
police details and client response now
I've done it in this way because when we
all received it it wasn't in day ordered
it was in it's in some some bit of a
pickle so I put it in some foreign order
and also a summary which I think I hope
you agree with me is helpful and helps
us but if we turn to the matter of the
of um
July
your note
that the police do make reference in
their representation so there's nothing
new that at six minutes past three
there's an allegation of sexual uh
sexual assault or an offense yes
at the premises yeah does everyone one
see that
yeah now in the Chris and Cat reports
[Applause]
that's been pretty
um you'll see
the pad number and it's pages one of
seven have you got that in front of you
members
one of seven
[Music]
because you can see on the grid that
I've provided it gives you the cad
number
that is the number that corresponds with
the police paper and and it has the cad
number at the top on the left hand side
and on the right hand side it says page
one of seven and it then sets the date
out and the alleged events
so with your Indulgence Mr chairman when
you're ready could members just indicate
and Mr Creswell and say when they've got
those when they've got that to hand or
if Mr crystal hasn't I can just refer to
it
so go for what what page you're looking
at on it in their file
well I I don't know if um Mr Price can
tell me how you received the Chris and
CAD or the cad reports but I've got the
cad report for the date the 26th of July
and it consists of seven pages now I
don't know how that's been provided to
you
okay can I point clarification chair
please
yeah David
um obviously the cad reports are are to
remain confidential so
getting into dangerous territory here
when when asking a question
in relation to a cad report
I'm not I'm not
in Baltimore in a moment uh it's quite
clear I'm just asking if the counselors
got paper that's right they have the
paperwork for them I think we are going
into territory that is sensitive I think
in the circumstances it would be better
to do it in the sensitive room for
wanted for better phrase
that's heard in private
uh so Peter are you happy with this
uh well if it's the only way we're going
to move forward then yes let's get on
with it
Okay so
so are you
agreeable
um are we able to do that
um without going through uh moving the
motion to exclude the public
no we have to do I'm happy to do that
if you remove it I'll second it um
gone
well vote to exclude the public yeah
I agree yeah right so our vote to uh
exclude on the basis that the
subcommittee considers that the public
interest in excluding the public
outweighs the public interest in this
deliberation being held in the public it
is resolved that under Section 100a
stroke four of the Local Government Act
1972 that the public be excluded from
the meeting for items
30 it's got 13 on the agenda now for
what item would this be on the agenda
Karen questions
um
item five
yes on the grounds that it involves the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in part one schedule 12 of
the act on the ground set out in the
regulations of 14 stroke two on the
license in act 2003 hearing regulations
205.
so I'm going to move into
a guide and then we'll need Rob to stop
the live streaming please
foreign
we're going to responsible authorities
have they got any questions for Mr
Creswell uh the constabury to start with
have you got any questions no I have no
questions to rise
uh Environmental
Protection Officer and I'll just ask a
very simple question
um Mr Creswell um during your complaints
to the council
um can you confirm that you are made
aware of the difference of a complaint
concerning out yourself Behavior noise
nuisance and Licensing issues and
matters that would refer to the police
as well during that process
uh yes I was informed uh of the
procedure that I would need to take
and did you fill in any other forms and
send them to other agencies such as
anti-sized Behavior forms or
notifications to the safer neighbor team
for example
um I don't believe I did the same
neighborhood um I uh done the form for I
believe Catherine green at a license and
that's the way I approached it
thank you
okay
um a planning enforcement officer got
any questions for Mr Creswell
thank you Jen and no no questions for Mr
griswell thank you
all right or the committee uh start with
Peter B have you got any questions for
Mr Creswell and I think I've asked all
mine thank you
so have you got any uh no further
questions thank you
all right uh David Price
licensing officer
no points of clarification chair
okay that's that then great thank you
very much and uh we'll now move on
to the premise license holder to present
their case so um David dads would you
like to
do your presence I think the procedure
is that isn't the procedure that the
other parties go first and I go in
effect last until I hear from now from
the police or the other responsible
authorities in interested parties
I've got you down his neck actually okay
well I can I can go next that's fine
I think just just for clarity
um so far as the license holder is
concerned you basically give can give
your closing address as the last thing
before uh any uh the subcommittee
retires Mr dad's
yes thank you it's only that um
um my submissions will now have to be
more Fuller because I I haven't heard
from the police but I will I will do my
best to to be succinct okay thank you
um
the uh but because I'm going to start
and I'm going to potentially start and I
think I'm going to start with the police
evidence uh we're going to have to go
into private again I'm afraid
so Mr chairman can we go into private so
I can make my submissions in relation to
the police part and then once I finished
that we can then go into open if you
wish
okay I will need to vote to um
screw the public again I believe that we
exclude the public so that we can press
on
do you need to read out
yeah
will Mr dorrington have a chance to
speak at some point as well
uh legal
yeah he gets a opportunity
to speak
thank you very much
yeah it's like Iran isn't it I started
later on yeah
and thank you okay
yeah that's later on in the mean right
so should I read this out again
to exclude the public
yes please
okay on the basis
that the subcommittee considers that the
public interest in excluding the public
outweighs the public interest in its
deliberation being held in the public it
is resolved that under Section 100a
stroke four of the Local Government Act
1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for item what item is this then
what number I am six still on items
five item five on the grounds that it
involves a likely disclosure of exempt
information as defined in part one of
schedule 12 of the act on the ground set
out in the regulations 14 stroke two of
the licensing act 2003 hearing
regulations 2005 right we're now going
to
private
yeah second dude you wait for Rob to
stop the streaming again
thank you